while we're heading east now was our
exclusive home tours continue with Real
Housewives of New York City and
socialite Dorinda medley is the widow of
a former partner in a hedge fund company
she is worth a reported 20 million
dollars so what does all that money buy
well Dorinda it's gonna show you
welcome to bluestone Manor maybe whoa it
has nine bedrooms and I'd say it's about
eleven thousand square feet but who's
coming right across 18 serene acres
Dorinda x' massachusetts country home
has been her sanctuary what is this an
interrogation I can just plate you right
down I want to light my house on fire
right now
burn it down okay well her sanctuary
when the rest of the housewives aren't
visiting all day I made it nice I
decorated it no one give a day themself
then you all go home they're here you
know we have our thing we have our drama
they leave and I let all the energy leak
with them and I do a little saging
afterwards from the billiard room to her
bedroom every once in a while we'll film
up here the producers find that I've
snuck away and I'm laying in my bed
watching TV to the guest rooms sometimes
occupied by fellow castmates LuAnn
Ramona this real housewife from New York
has found her paradise but in last
week's reunion show it was paradise lost
as Dorinda faced some nasty accusations
from Sonja daddy no drugs I don't do to
everybody would do all these drugs don't
with Hannah live with me I'm home every
night I think it's hilarious
I think it's poor Sonja's trying to be
relevant because Bethenny made these
comments and then poor Sonya had to run
with something what does she have I mean
consider the source as part two of the
reunion promises to be just as dramatic
Bethenny I hurt my feelings I will not
have that I listen to all of us have
barely spoken since the reunion it was a
tough for union I'm been laying in bed
thinking how can you go back in the fall
and I'll sit together
have any kind of friendship or anything
because horrible things were said about
person based on nothing based on no
facts just if you want to say it throw
it out there and I never saw the
housewives go to that that level so I
think people are really damaged